[Music]
[Applause]
next
guest eric branch the 49ers beat writer
for the san francisco chronicle
uh let me start with kyle shanahan
what's the local opinion of
of kyle and his uh his personality
well i think the the local opinion has
been very positive
you know great offensive play caller
kind of this quarterback whisper however
i think thursday night
the narrative could change dramatically
um and i think a lot of people will be a
little apoplectic
if it if it is mac jones yeah but it
feels like he knows who his guy
is though eric like that i don't think
you make this deal
going hey there's three guys up there
that we may like i mean that's that's a
that's a big commitment it's like buying
an engagement ring and saying hey there
are a lot of women out there that i
might give it to
like that you don't you don't do that
with the draft
yeah i'm with you i mean i really
thought when they made this trade
they at that point they'd had over two
months to investigate
you know presumably these three guys uh
you know heavily and you know there's
only so much you can do
i mean was there really going to be this
significant shift
after the second pro day for justin
fields or the samford trey lance
were they going to uncover something in
a zoom meeting that said oh my gosh
you know let's say it was mack jones
that they traded up to number three for
oh my gosh what he just did on the board
in this zoom meeting
makes me reconsider everything and it's
not matt jones so
yeah i mean obviously there's so much
smoke around matt jones
i feel like you know based on that
kyle shanahan whispering in my ear but i
feel like
you know just putting it all together it
will be mac jones
and i just have a hard time believing
that this last month where they were
able to do more investigating change
change that at all why is mac jones kyle
shanahan's kind of quarterback
well so matt jones you know as we all
know
he's the type of pocket passer that you
know kyle has preferred
and work with you know whether because
he
drafted you know a kirk cousins in the
fourth round inherited matt ryan
traded for jimmy garoppolo that is his
type of quarterback and for
for shanahan it is all about can you
deliver from the pocket
can you follow the instructions can you
find the open man
and that is priority a b c and d
and so if you can do other stuff that's
wonderful
you know if the left tackle you know
falls down and you've got to go make a
play as a quarterback
and save the day if kyle makes a bad
play call against a blitz
and you know you can get out of danger
and salvage it
wonderful but that is all secondary to
doing the job from the pocket
and so if you trade two first round
picks and a
third round pick you know matt jones
cannot be kirk cousins i mean
kyle has to view him as a pocket passing
machine
i mean he has to be in in kyle's view
you know it's a bit much to you know
invoke a drew brees a hall of famer
you know but he has to you know kyle has
to believe he must have that type of
potential
so that's who kyle wants the type of
quarterback kyle wants and if trey lance
or justin fields
he views them as like you know i see
that or i can see how
they can develop into that pocket passer
that's who i want
um but if he knows that he has that in
matt jones i would think that's why he's
he's been sold on max jones what's jimmy
garoppolo's future
well i asked uh
kyle you know yesterday uh they had
their pre-draft zoom meeting uh kyle and
john lynch
will jimmy garoppolo you know can you
say with certainty jimmy garoppolo oh
wait wait wait wait
let me let me play that i didn't know
that that was you eric
so uh yeah i would here's here's eric's
question
yesterday to uh kyle shanahan can you
say with certainty that jimmy garoppolo
will be on the roster on
sunday um i can't guarantee that anybody
in the world will be alive sunday so i
can't guarantee who will be on our
roster on sunday
so that goes for all of us getting a lot
of play today
there eric with that question and that
answer
yeah you didn't you didn't know you're
going to have a big start
i did not but did anybody follow up and
say coach hypothetically if jimmy is
still alive on sunday
assuming he's alive here like um
what's jimmy's future there well
i hope you have your will prepared and
everything just in case dan but um
uh jimmy's future you know kyle did go
on to say
you know that they're gonna have a
rookie quarterback it's a wonderful
position for them to be
in you know jimmy's won big games in the
past
when he's been healthy he's a proven
quarterback
and so that's great insurance um
however if he's not going to say with
certainty he's not going to be traded
during the draft
then you know i i would think they're
going to be picking up the phone when
whoever it is is it the broncos he's got
a great
john lynch has a very close relationship
with
john elway you know obviously the
patriots
don't think they're going to be you know
content to just roll with cam newton so
it wouldn't be surprising however i
think they'd still have to be blown away
because i really do they're sincere in
thinking
we do have a great insurance plan i mean
jimmy garoppolo could obviously be the
the best backup in the nfl and the 49ers
it's not like they're you know a bottom
feeder you know team with the number
three pick
they are a team with you know i think
legitimate contending if not super bowl
aspirations
and so you know if it's matt jones if
it's trey lance it was justin fields
if they showed they're not ready or if
they get in
and then they struggle then it's like
okay well we still have jimmy garoppolo
um they don't really have another viable
potential starter
you know in the quarterback room right
now so it would be like
okay if this rookie struggles it's uh
josh rosen
um there's a difference there
if the fans were drafting on thursday
who would the 49er fans take
you know i think you know i'm basing
this off social media
um and uh but i i think overwhelmingly
it would be justin fields um and i think
that's just because
i think there are concerns with trey
lance because it's you know you can't
play western illinois
uh you know in the nfl he hasn't played
a game since
he's played one one start since january
2020
so i think everyone likes him no one
there wouldn't be
uh revolting if he was picked however i
think just because justin fields he's
played at a big time program
he's had the production um he's done it
from the pocket
obviously he's dynamic more so than
mac jones obviously so uh i really think
justin fields would be the pick and of
course
uh there's been reports uh by notable
national
uh at least one notable national figure
saying the person that they will not
take is justin fields
so well it should be fun there eric i
and i look forward to kyle shanahan's
press conference after the first round
you know i hope we're all live to uh to
hear that
but uh you know there's no guarantee
eric just remember that i'll
i'll wait for your next question for
kyle shanahan
well yeah thank you i didn't i wasn't
expecting that response but
it was i guess it was an artful dodge or
maybe
it was a very dark dodge by kyle yeah
i don't know if it was artful at all but
uh
uh
have fun on thursday there eric thank
you for joining us
all right i appreciate it take care
that's uh eric branch the 49ers beat
writer for the san francisco chronicle